à l'issue de deux journées de travaux du
comité central du parti communiste qui a
décidé entre autres de la tenue d'un
congrès extraordinaire pour la
mi-octobre
georges marchais a déclaré ce matin
devant la presse que son parti a appelé
au rassemblement le plus large afin de
conduire dans les meilleures conditions
l'expérience du socialisme nous luttons
pour un changement réel mais raisonnable
dire at il fini cette caricature que
l'on fait trop souvent de nous nous ne
sommes pas des partisans du tout ou rien
il est évident qu'il faut tout faire
pour créer les conditions du
développement de l'unité et de l'action
des travailleurs des masses populaires
pour la défense de leurs intérêts pas
besoin de justifier que c'est légitime
il suffit il suffira plus tôt de prendre
connaissance du nième plan d'austérité
de monsieur giscard d'estaing pour
comprendre il va y avoir des intérêts à
des fins pendant une période qui shirt à
la mode était giscard à la barre on
pourrait maintenant a ajouté qu'avec
giscard c'est vraiment le coup de barre
pour les contribuables
bonjour je marchais le départ de jean
jacques servan shreiber du gouvernement
prouve le peu de sérieux de nouvelle
équipe ministérielle
puis il parle de l'abaissement de l'âge
électoral à 18 ans ils en ont fait dans
les rues des manifestations
les jeunes pour avoir ce droit de vote à
18 ans par conséquent je considère que
c'est un succès à l'actif des forces
démocratiques qui à l'opposé des forces
conservatrices font confiance elle a la
jeunesse
naturellement j'ai quand même un petit
regret
c'est qu'il n'ait pas décidé plus tôt
peut-être que